pierre premier dit pierre legrand
imposant par la taille plus de deux
mètres grand par le pouvoir
il est le tsar de russie de la dynastie
des romanov le grand trianon de
versailles retrace son séjour à
versailles en 1717 pierre le grand a été
le grand réformateur de la russie celui
qui a fait entrer la russie dans la
modernité
c'était à la fois un grand conquérant
c'était aussi un esprit animé d'une
curiosité universel et venant en france
il a souhaité justement assouvir cette
curiosité universel et en achetant des
objets en allant vers les artistes on en
attirant certains ou en russie l
exposition présente 155 oeuvres issues
des collections du musée de l'ermitage à
saint pétersbourg ville fondée par
pierre le grand
des oeuvres permettant de découvrir pas
à pas les 12 jours passés au grand
trianon
on retrouve des objets uniques vous avez
par exemple costumes d'été que pierre
legrand portait lors de cette visite
protocolaire
donc nous les exposons ainsi que son
nécessaire de voyage comme par exemple
un coffre à pharmacie ou une cassette
personnelle du tsar un voyage
diplomatique réalisé peu après la fin du
règne de louis xiv dans un versailles au
sommet un séjour qui lance les relations
franco russes